what affects your mind yeah and how does
big farm affect your mind
number one
the information that comes through
legitimate sources
that doctors have been taught to rely on
evidence-based medicine the articles in
peer-reviewed journals
the guidelines that are issued now those
are problematic
because
when an article is peer-reviewed and
published in a respected journal
people
and doctors
obviously assume
that
the peer reviewers have anal have had
access to the data and they've
independently analyzed the data
and they corroborate the findings in the
manuscript that was submitted or they
give feedback to the authors and say we
disagree with you on this point and
would you please check our analysis and
if you agree with us making that's what
they assume the peer review process is
but it's not
the peer reviewers don't have the data
the peer reviewers have the manuscript
that's been submitted
by the
usually in conjunction with or by the
drug
company that manufactures the drug
so peer reviewers
are
unable to perform the job
that doctors think they're performing
to vet the data to assure that it's
accurate and reasonably complete
they can't do it
and then we have the clinical practice
guidelines which are increasingly more
important as
the information
the flow of information keeps getting
brisker and brisker and docs need to get
to the bottom line quickly clinical
practice guidelines become much more
important
and we assume
that the authors of those clinical
practice guidelines have independently
analyzed the data from the clinical
trials and make their recommendations
that set the standards of care based on
their analysis that's not what happens
the
experts who write the clinical trials
rely
almost entirely
on the
publications presenting the results of
the clinical trials which are peer
reviewed but the peer reviewers haven't
had access to the data
so we've got a system of the highest
level of evidence
that doctors have been trained over and
over again to rely on to practice
evidence-based medicine to be good
doctors
that has not been verified do you think
that data
that's coming from the pharma companies
do you think they're uh
what level of manipulation is going on
with that data is it the at the study
design level is it that literally
there's some data that you
just keep off you know
keep out of the charts
keep out of the
the aggregate analysis then you then
publish
or is it the worst case which is
just change some of the numbers
it happened all three happen i can't i
don't know what the denominator is but i
spent about
10 years in litigation
and for example in vioxx uh which was
withdrawn from the market in 2004 in the
biggest drug recall in american history
uh the problem was that um it got
recalled when a study that merck
sponsored
showed that vioxx doubled the risk more
than double the risk of heart attacks
strokes
and blood clots serious blood clots it
got pulled then but there was a study
that a bigger study that had been
published in 2000 in the new england
journal of medicine
that showed that vioxx was a better drug
for
arthritis and pain
not because it was more effective it's
no more effective than aleve or advil
but because it was less likely to cause
serious gi complications bleeds and
perforations in the gut
now in that study that was published in
the new england journal
that was never corrected
it was a little bit
modified
15 months after the drug was taken off
the market but never corrected
merck left out three heart attacks
and the fda knew that merck left out
three heart attacks and the fda's
analysis of the of the data from that
study
said that they weren't gonna the fda
wasn't gonna do
the analysis without the three heart
attacks in it
and the important part of this story is
that there were 12 authors listed on
that study in the new england journal
two were merck employees they knew about
the three heart attacks that had been
omitted
the other
10 authors the academic authors
didn't know about it they hadn't seen
that data
so merck just
they had an excuse it's complicated and
the fda didn't accept it so there's no
reason to go into it
but merck just left out the three heart
attacks and the three heart attacks that
may seem 300 attacks in a 10 000 person
study may seem like nothing
except they completely changed the
statistics so that had the three heart
attacks been included the only
conclusion that merck could have made
was that vioxx significantly increased
the risk of heart attack
and they abbreviated their endpoint
from heart attacks strokes and blood
clots to just heart attacks yeah
so those are maybe in their mind they're
also playing by the rules because of
some technical excuse that you mentioned
that was rejected
how can this no because this is no no
let me interrupt no that's not true
um the study was completed the blind was
broken meaning they looked at the data
in march of 2000 the article was
published in the new england journal in
november of 2000
in march of 2000 there was an email
by the head scientist
that was published in the wall street
journal
that said
the day that the data were unblinded
that it's a shame that the
cardiovascular events are there
but
the drug will do well
and we will do well
but removing the three heart attacks how
does that happen like uh
who has to convince themselves is this
pure malevolence
um
you have to be the judge of that but the
person who was in charge of the data
safety monitoring board
issued a letter that said they'll stop
counting cardiovascular events
a month before the trial is over
and they'll continue counting gi events
and that person got a contract to
consult with merck for five thousand
dollars a day i think for 12 days a year
for one or two years
that was signed that
contract
was signed within two weeks of the
decision
to stop counting heart attacks i won't
understand that man or woman
i wanna
i want it's the uh i've been reading a
lot about nazi germany and and thinking
a lot about the good germans
because
i want to understand so that we can each
encourage each other to take the small
heroic actions that prevents that
because it feels to me
removing malevolence from the table
where it's just a pure psychopathic
person
that there's just no
momentum created by the game like you
mentioned yes
and so
it takes reversing the momentum
within the company i think requires
many small acts of heroism not gigantic
i'm going to leave and become a
whistleblower and publish a book about
it
but small
quiet acts of pressuring against this
like what are we doing here we're trying
to help people is this the right thing
to do looking in the mirror constantly
asking is this the right thing to do
i mean that's how that's what integrity
is
uh acknowledging the pressures you're
under and then still be able to zoom out
and think what is the right thing to do
here
you